i'm kevin and i miss you back like the
hardest thing is you have to really like
i'm a celiac not like I'm doing this
because I want to be better at mai tai
chi but you have to be like hey this is
serious for me and some places will have
like gluten friendly menus and you'll be
like gluten friendly we'll have to stop
me go to a gay friendly pub that's a new
place now gay free pub yeah good job
people on the bottom level who just like
conscious about eating wheat they want
to be better at things like yoga then
right above that there's luton
intolerant maybe looks like an allergy
that hasn't been diagnosed but they
don't feel good from eating it then
there's like straight up an allergy to
gluten you're going to like shock and
then on top of that is this thing called
celiacs disease and it's like the worst
of the worst it's a silent killer give
you cancer in the long run you're not
absorbing as many nutrients you're not
like living is healthy you don't feel as
good you're tired you're pulling all the
time yeah it's like all the time all the
time literally non-stop how you get
diagnosis yeah the doctors Indies what
it was like yeah you keep going when I
first found out my doctor told me that I
would be a celiac I thought he said we'd
and I was like what and he was like you
get you can have weed anymore and I was
like how do you even know what Benny
just like went into foods that you could
put marijuana brownies cookies pizza
pasta and I was like that's creative and
then I realized he was talking about
wheat and I was like oh which is pretty
funny I just confess to the world what
celiacs least favorite band what wheatus
no I would like to say to all the
brewers out there that I think making
gluten-free beer is a wonderful and good
thing to do and you should all take it
on but you should learn how to do it
really really well and don't make like
boring beers that don't taste like
anything I think it's celiacs want
exciting and flavorful beer just like
everybody else
because i'm just a teenage sealy actress
i challenge you to rap about three
things medically diagnosed disorders i
calling too much attention to yourself
and being the center of attention and
miss diagnosis cool medically diagnosed
until misdiagnosed me dr. mess and
calling too much attention to yourself
lovely stuff this will be a freestyle
about mercy I woke up in the morning and
with urgency I got my local bus to the
surgery I saw my doctor yeah degree md
are saying mr. doctor what is wrong with
me he says first you don't need to say
mr. doctor it's already attacked oh that
i got from my university I went my
reward I went to lse and then two arcs
bored because economics is confusing I
was like whoa there's no need to have
two degrees on show Abby live people
start to hate your mate if you duplicate
your certification like the center of
attention and I'm clenching my buttocks
I bend over and I stuff to kick like an
ox because I see the camera the lube
egos this I know I'm in line for a
diagnosis pathology it goes up on it
lingers he examines first width or five
of his fingers it's a diagnosis that I
know is so hasty it's like KFC cuz it's
finger-licking tasty the diagnosis I got
busy up Annie he took the oath that was
bar here pufferty's was like Socrates
and Plato but he has always got such a
big ego ego ah I took like Freud he was
the center of attention so what tried to
avoid the discussion and I'm Russian and
then I just go for the RB like in the
mental fervor he is
diagnose me in the wrong way I'd be like
why are these words that you're trying
to save they're not correct I stand
erect stand to attention I want to go
back to the past the old declension I
get the details through he does blood
samples he took a whole armful it was
ample I'm like so why'd you say to me
you had a bad disease like cancer or HIV
I didn't it was just HPV yeah you will
try this because lots of people have the
human papillomavirus it was fine I went
out in the street I danced around threw
confetti at was so neat and people
saying Chris you're always in the middle
and that is how i finish people staring
at the salt riddle there you go yeah
yeah was as good as a gluten-free beer
yeah it's just this tasty as a
gluten-free beer make more losing beer
make it more